gentlemen i can't tell you how much of a
pleasure it was to see basically the
gang back together again in season five
william to who do we get to give the
credit for all of these amazing
comebacks and the way that you
spin old lore into new stories
uh well that's really the the writers
the creators come up with the timing for
that we knew that they were we have a
list in a little canon of characters
that may or may not come back into the
show but they have to come right into
the right place at the right plot point
um so uh we're we're really not involved
in the timing of that um but it has to
be natural and it's been organic from
the i think was a season two when the
original cobra kai's came back and then
season three elizabeth chu came back and
you know and and uh we're kind of
hitting some some bells along the way
but it has to make sense in the plot it
can't just be for the sake of it and
they have to serve the plot and drive it
forward and then turn these characters
upside down and inside out and i think
that's been really fun for the creators
to reimagine the characters today and
for us as actors to get to interpret
that
and and to play that it keeps it fresh
so we're not playing you know
leaning on yesterday but these are
evolved people with uh three decades of
life before we since the last time we
saw them and it's always fun to meet
those people and everybody that's come
on
um across the board is more than knocked
it out of the park and um and it's a
thrill to watch and be a part of as far
as also in as well as birthing all the
new characters that are uh that are part
of the universe now
ralph you've said that as much as you
know you've had your issues with karate
kid part three having silver as the
villain here is something that that
movie gave this show and it's been
amazing right has has the show had you
look back
on uh on the movie series kind of in a
different way have you reflected on it
in a different light
um and it's interesting i don't i i
haven't gone back to
to look at it that way um uh
the karate kid part three acrylic part
two i did wind up watching recently
because tamlin tamida who played kumako
we did an audio commentary for it and
that was really kind of special to kind
of do that and watch the movie for the
first time together and
talking about that but but with karate
kid part three i have not gone back to
it but what i have
uh not for any
you making me think maybe that would be
a fun thing to do me and thomas just
like cracking a few cold ones it is such
fertile ground for story and
and depth of character and what these
actors what the writers have done
like you've mentioned to evolve these
characters and and and and forge
pathways you didn't expect it's beyond
my expectations and and without it i i
wrote about this recently i you know
even the shortcomings from the original
film series are now giving bearing fruit
going forward and creating
life and directions i i did not expect
and uh and and layers to characters it's
really uh it's really commendable and
and kind of you know unique and awesome
i know a ton of people that would be on
board for you guys cracking a bunch of
questions
and commenting on the third movie i
every season we get
really great like
massive action scene brawls this season
has one that's like just blows the roof
off of everything um william
what is the prep like
how much does it hurt the next day
like
tell us about the process of doing those
yeah what prep we're getting really wet
we'd like to think we have a lot of prep
time i mean there's so many fights
throughout the season in this that we're
constantly i mean there's there's a
stunt team the choreographer fight
coordinator and they're constantly you
know maybe a week out from the next
fight coming up so if we have a fight
and see episode five they're still
working out two three and four fights so
then what they'll do is they'll do a
previz they'll shoot it with just the
stunt guys so they know what they're
doing they'll present that to the
creators and then you know usually i
mean sometimes we'll have the luxury of
a few days ramp up to that or a week
maybe so it's about being prepared
physically you have to be stretched out
and limber and awake and alert because
there's a lot of feet coming at your
head and then you're working with some
really amazing martial artists and
talented stunt guys that you know uh do
a lot of the work for you and then you
know you're not clashing arms and
hurting when ralph and i fight um you
know we we both walk away with bruises
brews is central because you know we're
not pulling our when we did karate kid
we had so much time to rehearse that we
would get within a millimeter of each
other and not hit each other but now
we're doing it it's like i'll throw a
hook and he's like bam with that with
that baseball bat bony arm boning arm i
got the money beat up so it's uh you
know when we're working with the actors
i think we tend to get a little more
beat up yes for sure the stunt guys are
you know way more gentle where and plus
you know you're the actor so you're
getting that energy up and you're you
know you
you're giving your performance and even
though you you try i mean like you billy
said with the original karate kid those
fight scenes we had weeks months on and
it was a ballet it was a tango it was we
barely touched each other where now um
we don't have a lot of time you know but
we do it in pieces um i mean in karate
kid we ran those sequences yeah
absolutely we shot the final fight in
the karate kid front to back front to
back no no entire thing right and then
we and then we break it down for tighter
shots but when now we do almost
everything in pieces the stunt guys the
stunt guys will do a full run in cobra
kai but then when we get in we have to
do it in chunks because it just we don't
have the prep time you don't know what's
coming and when someone's foot is coming
it would be impossible to do it we would
need six months out to get it all right
i mean so everybody's working really
hard and really fast and
it's it's it's really grueling you got
to be stretched uh i pulled the knee
last in the season in one of the fights
um you know i i was wearing van tennis
shoes and and slipped on a mat and
you know just some
blame it on the vans you know so it's uh
it's physical but it's fun it's
challenging we're up for the challenge
you know we got more in the tank right
ralph a little bit more you got a couple
more rounds in us as much as the fans
want yeah yeah i love that guys you're
walking the walk
legends hey thanks so much for the time
guys
you